well no surprise to tell you it is
absolutely
jubilant a lot of people at the match to
tonight have traveled from
all over the world not just from across
the european union but from america
to dubai and other places of course fans
couldn't come directly from
the uk well let's have a chat with some
of the people who have actually traveled
over here
i've got henry henry what was it like in
there
have you gone all shy
you told me what was it like uh it was a
really big stadium
and i really liked it it was my first
time in a football stadium
and i love it the angle 1-4-0
and you've traveled here with your from
switzerland with your dad
luke who is british yes luke did you
ever expect four
nil no no i would i when you get to this
stage you always expect a tight game but
luckily it was a great result
it was worth the 12-hour traffic jam
yesterday from switzerland to italy
so i know it was a fantastic result and
a fast fantastic first game for the boys
a lot of people were worried that
because so few uh
england fans could travel here the
atmosphere in the stadium wouldn't be so
great
do you disagree no the atmosphere is
always great at england games wherever
you go i've been to see them in
switzerland the atmosphere is fantastic
and there's so many
brits all over europe that uh can get
luckily go and see and support the team
which was good and i think they
appreciated it
now i know you have traveled from either
even further afield where have you come
from
what what did what did you think of the
match uh the match was fantastic we've
had a really good time
the atmosphere was great even though it
was only 20 full
it's the atmosphere has been phenomenal
so yeah
and of course a lot of england fans were
really sad that they couldn't be here
tonight but now they're going to get a
chance because england's next game will
be at wembley yeah
back back at home where 60 000 fans i
believe so
that's where it's going to really hit
home in the semifinals semi-finals we
were just looking to be here for this
for tonight's game for sure